cette ergothérapeute a pour mission
d'aider rachel lassonde a re devenir
autonome
réapprendre même les plus petits gestes
je m'assois
rachel la sonde lutte pour retrouver la
mobilité perdu après une opération au
cerveau
trois professionnels se déplacent ici un
tour de rôle au total une trentaine
d'heures de service à chaque semaine en
ergots moi je peux aller de 4 à 5 fois
dans une semaine je les vois pour 45
minutes en physio c'est la même chose
c'est avant la pandémie cette
réhabilitation aurait eu lieu à
l'hôpital en fait d'un contexte la
pandémie on a dû faire de la place à
l'hôpital pour accueillir des usagers
qui ont la coved qu'on appelait la zone
rouge mais depuis janvier faute de lits
à l'hôpital de réadaptation
on a déplacé la réhabilitation d'environ
80 patients lavallois à leur domicile
une transformation forcé mais qui semble
efficace surtout parce que la
réhabilitation se fait en fonction du
domicile
pour les créances et plus réaliste il
voit un peu pourquoi qu'on fait que
l'intervention québec je veut
généraliser cette approche baptisée
congé précoce assister ça permet à
l'individu de faire sa réadaptation dans
son milieu de vie et en plus un gros
impact sur notre réseau de la santé
puisque sa décharge les lie sa décharge
les infirmières
avaient co la
rochelle la sonde pense que la présence
dassier a contribué à ces progrès ma
mère bouger pub au japon et ne bougeait
pas de bol et elle souhaite que ces
soins à domicile lui permettront bientôt
dans sortie c'est marcher marcher un
jour mais comme j'étais ici david
gêne-t-il radio-canada laval